soit fou se justifie l'élargissement du
marché comme pétrole les pays
producteurs vont sans doute l'augmenter
andré giraud prévoit des répercussions
sur le prix de l'essence iran avec
l'armée le chat tente de reprendre la
situation en main reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux
assises du nord la peine de mort requise
contre serge ferhat watts mais à
messieurs bonsoir à combien perdons nous
notre essence au 1er janvier
à combien la paieront nous au 31 et 179
le prix du super aura-t-il alors dépassé
les 3 francs et bien la réponse à toutes
ces questions se trouvent en ce moment
entre les mains de 13 ministres réunis à
partir de demain à abou dhabi ces sommes
représentent les pays exportateurs de
pétrole à l'ordre du jour de leur
conférence
la situation du nouveau prix du brut
gelé depuis un an et demi mais avant
même que les miss ne se réunisse tous
semblent d'accord pour une majoration
d'environ 10% en plusieurs étapes dans
quelle mesure et cette hausse sera
t-elle répercuter sur les produits
français et notamment sur l'essence eh
bien je pense que nous aurons la réponse
d'andré girons le ministre de
l'industrie dans le courant de ce
journal andré giraud qui vient de
répondre il ya quelques instants
seulement à jacques merino et dont nous
j'espère pourront diffuser l'interview
dans le courant journal l'europe
monétaire se consolide
alors qu'on l'avait jugée mal en point
au lendemain du sommet de bruxelles la
semaine dernière voilà que leur tour les
irlandais ont choisi de rejoindre le sm
c'est à dire le système monétaire
européen
dans quinze jours les italiens avaient
pris la même décision avant-hier seul
donc les anglais boudent encore philippe
sassier oui vous savez le système
monétaire européen c'est un petit peu
comme dans une course cycliste
les performances d'une monnaie comme
celle d'un coureur s'apprécie par
rapport aux performances du peloton dans
une robe monétaires ainsi c'est bien la
france aurait été la lanterne rouge en
quelque sorte se peut le temps et la
situation du franc aurait été assez
périlleuse avec l'entrée de la lire
italienne de là
livre irlandaise est bien le franc ne
sera pas la monnaie la plus faible du
futur système monétaire européen et les
chances de réussite de ce futur système
son dock améliorée mais aussi un autre
motif de satisfaction politique celui là
aujourd'hui
la presse étrangère souligne dans son
ensemble que la france a eu raison de se
montrer ferme lors des dernières
discussions au sommet de bruxelles le
ton a changé
il ya une semaine on parlait d'un demi
échec d'helmut schmidt et surtout de
valéry giscard d'estaing
aujourd'hui avec le ralliement de
l'irlande et de l'italie au système
monétaire européen bien la position
politique de la france et de l'allemagne
en europe et renforcer très certainement
jimmy carter devront obtenir poc lors
des discussions à la guadeloupe en
janvier prochain pour pas perdre de voix
pour autres voilà en tout cas qui venait
à point pour le nouveau ministre
français des affaires étrangères jean
françois poncet qui a effectué cet après
midi sa première intervention à
l'assemblée à propos de l'élargissement
de l'europe
si par égoïsme at il dit nous refusions
d'écouter les appels de la grèce du
portugal et de l'espagne
eh bien la france tournerait le dos aux
idéaux dont elle se réclame
et pour le ministre cette nouvelle étape
de la construction européenne est une
nécessité vitale entre nous sommes ici
sûrement non à nous souvenir fort où la
france était faible et on doute de sa
capacité à affronter d'éventuels
partenaires qui me même doutait de la
france c'est désormais une vite
historique que de reconnaître que la
france a pu jouer dans l'europe et dans
sa construction le rôle qui lui emmenait
est que la au cours de ces années rendu
compétitive sur le co2
c'est vrai que nous voulons rouge est
que nous sommes est organisée est aussi
humeur qui doit affirmer dans le monde
une personnalité et une volonté qui soit
authentiquement les siennes
l'organisation de leurs apps et quatre
traits de l'esprit qu'il a toujours
animé perdrait toute justification si
elle ne s'accompagnait pas d'une volonté
d'affirmation prendre et d'indépendance
notamment vis-à-vis des etats-unis
d'amérique
enfin ces torrents qui se fait est une
heure à part aux passions confédérés
elle respectera la personnalité de la
france lundi presse de sa défense et de
sa diplomatie
c'est un sable venise et que constitue
elle ne considère l accroche toi de
ployer seule influence sans rien perdre
de la capacité d'initiative propre qui
résultent sa vocation mondiale unis avec
ses partenaires pour une oeuvre de
prospérité et de justice la face ça
cessez jamais d'être elle-même donnera
ainsi l'exemple de la solidarité et de
la dépendance
voilà un débat qui s'est engagé alors
que ce dossier européen et bien
passionnés en france alors daniel brême
comment ça s'est passé à l'assemblée
quelle est votre impression générale de
ce débat bien écouter même les discours
les plus académique or seul est une
poche de venin ce qui a justifié cette
remarque de maurice faure au fond
l'europe est chargé de passion pour les
hommes politiques français ce qui n'est
pas le cas chez nous voilà
est-ce que vous avez l'impression quand
même que le débat un peu avancé écoutez
oui et non ici on a retrouvé les mêmes
positions mais les clivages sont très
nets et même les nuances à l'intérieur
des groupes se prendre un exemple par
exemple couve de murville dit très
nettement oui à l'entrée de l'espagne
dans le marché commun avec des
précautions mais monsieur debré lui
constaté d'ions peut pas dire non et il
en profite pour refaire le procès
d'intention habituel aux intentions du
gouvernement en matière d'indépendance
de la france
alors du côté des communistes on reprend
les mêmes alarme en insistant sur le
péril et la domination de l'allemagne et
en même temps on dit un non tout à fait
catégorique à l'entrée de l'espagne dans
la communauté on en profite au passage
pour décocher quelques coups de pieds
aux camarades socialistes et comment
françois mitterrand réplique à ses coups
de pied et bien ses ruades mitterrand
riposte jusqu'ici je n'ai entendu ni le
parti communiste ni les élus ni le rpr
demandé à quitter le marché commun et
dans un discours plutôt assez européen
monsieur mitterrand dit à quelle
condition son parti accepte l'entrée de
l'espagne dans la communauté à savoir
l'organisation de l'agriculture
l'organisation de l'industrie et
l'organisation des régions notamment
pour les salaires et ce sont des
conditions impératives
il nous reste l'udf comment ça s'est
passé eh bien écoutez là on fait
confiance au gouvernement pour mettre
les verrous il faut seulement monsieur
chine au monde une sorte de grenade vers
le rpr et dit certains ont des états
d'âme
est-ce que cela ne cache pas le désir de
déposer une motion de censure évidemment
nous attendons la réponse
daniel bref vous avez arpenté toute la
journée sur les pouvoirs du parlement
les remous dont on parlait au sein du
rpr hier il semble que le soufflet soit
un petit peu retombé aujourd'hui
oui c'est vrai et monsieur benhamadi que
l'escaladé terminée ils deviennent muets
comme des tombes on prépare le bon mais
les tranquillisants et il faut dire à
cela que il y a une certaine cette
satisfaction au mouvement parce que les
fédérations ont répondu à 100 % oui à
monsieur chirac et que d'autre part les
députés rpr n'aime pas qu'on parle de
division mais je vous donne rendez-vous
à mardi on en saura plus sur v et à
l'extérieur du parlement alain
peyrefitte lui-même a également
dédramatiser le débat en disant
aujourd'hui qu'il souhaitait plutôt
l'apaisement et l'union quant à jacques
chirac qui visiblement lui aussi a
décidé de freiner les ardeurs des uns et
les autres eh bien il est sorti de
l'hôpital mais il avant de se rendre
dans une clinique de cergy pontoise pour
sa rééducation
il n'a pas pu s'empêcher d'aller faire
un petit tour à l'hôtel de ville et il a
même joué ça pour l'anecdote mais c'est
significatif célébrer le mariage civil
de la petite fille du général de gaulle
cérémonie à laquelle assistaient madame
de gaulle
la gauche est bien la réponse de georges
marchais à la proposition de françois
mitterrand qui souhaitait réunir le
comité de liaison des trois partis de
gauche
pour l'heure c'est plutôt une fin de non
recevoir pas de proclamation sonore a
dit georges marchais mais des actions de
masse ont très puissante à la base
unitaire françois mitterrand voulait que
les communistes les radicaux de gauche
et les socialistes examine la politique
économique et sociale du gouvernement au
lendemain notamment de cette vague de
licenciements dans la sidérurgie
aujourd'hui encore on a eu la
confirmation de la suppression de 1700
emplois chez ce lac
aujourd'hui encore les ouvriers d'usinor
ont occupé des bureaux à
trith-saint-léger près de valenciennes
et puis aujourd'hui encore les lorrains
ont subi plus que réagit c'est bien le
sentiment de gérard inné et de patrick
voix qui reviennent d'hagondange 11000
habitants à une dizaine de kilomètres de
mélange cette pancarte remplace le
traditionnel panneaux de bienvenue une
commune de moselle particulièrement
frappés par la crise dans cette usine la
plus vieille du groupe sacilor 2000
licenciements ont été annoncés d'ici
1980 soit plus de la moitié des
effectifs
les premiers touchés seront les jeunes
et les plus de 56 ans qui seront mis en
pré retraite pour moi personnellement
bonbons
l'affairé classée à 57 ans passés je
peux plus recherchés du travail
d'ailleurs ici en moselle open ne
retrouverait pas pourtant la population
semble las et résignés ne comprends pas
cette restructuration l'emploi l'avenir
c'étaient les aciéries ses hauts
fourneaux ce décor on ne comprend pas
alors que les entreprises continuent à
former de jeunes sidérurgiste quand on a
commencé il y avait des débouchés paris
garantissait l'emploi
et puis après il me donne on sait que
c'était possible alors maintenant on va
nous n'est pas contraint prendront peut
rien faire conter remis notre chapeau
pour avoir à papier qu'on essaie de
faire autre chose
comment tu as trois classes et bas il ya
des empêcheurs des stages formation à
d'autres
d'autres métiers carrément recyclé quoi
mais pourtant c'est un métier qui te
plaît ce oui mais il n'y a pas d'avenir
on n'arrive pas trop de travail déjà il
ya aussi les jeunes qui reviennent
d'armes ils n'ont pas de travail
n'aurait alors on n'aura pas d'emplois
comme francis ils sont plus de 25 jeunes
à hagondange à suivre une formation de
sidérurgistes mais tous ne sont pas
prêts à quitter leur ville et encore
moins leur région leur conversion ils en
parlent ne savent pas très bien que fait
elle s'annonce difficile car si quelques
projets d'implantations industrielles
sont en cours de réalisation dans la
région
ils auront du mal à absorber toutes les
demandes d'emploi sur le seul bassin
sidérurgique lorrain se sont
douze mille emplois qui sont en train de
se créer en ce moment par des
entreprises qui ont décidé leur
investissement dans un passé récent
je cite par exemple renault véhicules
industriels dont il faut voir les
bâtiments à sortir de terre en ce moment
et qui embauche déjà peugeot citroën
renault en tout ceci fait environ 8000
emplois qui sont en train de donner lieu
à des embauches en ce moment à d'autres
implantations sont en cours de décision
sur l'ongle oui et tout ceci est une
reconversion à très court terme de la
lorraine seulement malheureusement 83
les indh à rodange qui à quelques
kilomètres à elle sera fermée depuis
longtemps et les emplois dont on a
besoin maintenant nous les avons pas en
plus de ça il faut dire que citroën le
procès de à une restructuration dans ces
établissements
et il y aura des mutations internes si
bien que sur les 3500 emplois il y aura
quelques centaines d'emplois
ouvert à la sidérurgie la reconversion
de la sidérurgie et déjà commencé mais
celle des hommes sera sans doute plus
difficile voilà 20h13 voici comme prévu
la réponse d'andré giro le ministre de
l'industrie à jacques martineau qui
voulait connaître les répercussions sur
le prix de l'essence de l'éventuelle
hausse du pétrole bien disons si vous le
voulez bien pour simplifier que selon
que la hausse retenue abu dhabi sera de
0 2 5 ou de 10 % l'incidence sur le prix
de l'essence serait une augmentation de
0,3 ou 6 centimes par litre cette
augmentation s'ajouteraient évidemment à
l'augmentation fiscale qui elle est de
croix que je crois de 13 centimes
exactement par contre il peut y avoir
des facteurs en plus ou en moins
notamment la suppression de
fameuse cagnotte qui apportera aux
consommateurs un avantage de 6 centimes
85 alors pendant que le ministre parlait
j'ai fait un rapide calcul le super
étape de france 38 à peu près en france
13 centimes de plus c'est ce qui était
prévu la hausse fiscale et 6 centimes si
jamais le brut passe à 10 % de plus à
abou dhabi vous voyez on arriverait à
peu près à deux francs 87
je crois quand n 2 est pour l'instant la
première station à vous annoncer ce si
j'espère que ça se confirmera bien que
la nouvelle soit évidemment par très
très bonne la politique étrangère
maintenant avec tout d'abord ce space ce
suspense pardon à washington le
président carter s'apprête dans les
heures peut-être même dans les minutes
qui vont suivre a annoncé une nouvelle
qualifiée d'importante
il a pour cela solliciter un temps
d'antenne auprès des trois grandes
chaînes de télévision
mais il ne le fera pas avant le retour à
washington de certaines sont socata
d'état alors bien évidemment on pense
tout de suite qu'il va s'agir d'une
intervention sur le proche orient
rien ne va plus en effet entre
israéliens et égyptiens jérusalem a
rejeté en effet ce matin et demande
égyptienne de modifications des traités
de paix jerusalem refusant de signer
pour l'heure la réunion du cabinet
israélien ce matin s'est tenue dans une
atmosphère de profonde irritation à
l'égard des états unis
et c'est justement ce qui ressort des
déclarations de monsieur begin
il a rejeté catégoriquement les
exigences égyptienne et il affirme que
la non signature du traité de paix
retombe entièrement sur le caire on le
premier ministre israélien le président
sadate vide de toute signification les
accords de camp david
notamment sur les points de la
cisjordanie et de l' échange
d'ambassadeurs entre les deux pays il
estime également que la position
américaine est unilatérale et penche du
côté égyptien
monsieur médine a tout de même déclaré
que la négociation allait se poursuivre
conte parvenir à un accord voilà c'est
clair donc menahem begin a accusé
l'egypte de porter l'entière
responsabilité de la non signature du
traité alors vu du caire pierre serra
j'imagine qu'il suffit d'inverser les
termes de la proposition affirmation
israël
pas tout à fait vous savez je crois que
d'abord on peut dire une chose c'est que
la situation est grave n'est pas
dramatique parce que ni monsieur
beginning monsieur sadate jusqu'à
présent ne dramatisez l'idée de reporter
le délai de la falaise la date de la
signature qui était prévu pour le 17
décembre
ce qu'il faut quand même me voir dans
tout cela c'est que d'une part de chaque
côté de deux parties on sait très bien
quelles sont les raisons de l'autre même
si on admet pas ça aussi c'est très
important
et puis il reste que finalement la
signature peut être l'avenir de monde à
l'autre peut-être que carter annonce
reste à tout à l'heure
et puis aussi le fait que on se souvient
quand les négociations les dernières
négociations de washington ont commencé
c'était la grande euphorie un peu un peu
forcé peut-être mesure va signe envoyé
tout de suite on ne l'a pas fait et ce
qui fait que le délai qui a couru depuis
le moment là des premières moutures du
traité et fait prête jusqu'à maintenant
et a fait que tous les détails sur
lesquels auraient fermé les yeux ou les
concessions pour les fêtes sont
finalement ressortis alors ce qui est
dangereux c'est finalement sur scène
quatre équipes tout va ressortir pour le
problème voilà en tout cas peut-être 30
m2 va-t-il pouvoir rapporté lundi des
éléments décisifs dans cette affaire car
mouflets dyan le ministre israélien des
affaires étrangères participera en
direct à l'émission de jean-pierre
elkabbach et de roger benhamou une
mission que nous avons avec toute la
rédaction décidé de consacrer toute
entière à la paix dans le monde
émission dont je vous reparlerai à la
fin de ce journal
et puis ce lundi-là sera aussi une
journée de deuil en iran ainsi en a
décidé l'opposition religieuse et civile
ceci pour protester contre les
incidences sanglantes qui ont émaillé
les manifestations pro-gouvernementales
à chiraz et haïssent parents on parle
vous le savez de plus de 50 morts depuis
dimanche
ce soir nous avons décidé de consacrer
un gros dossier à ce problème iranien
car avons le très souvent on ne comprend
pas toujours ce qui au delà de la haine
du chat unis l'opposition laïque encore
minoritaires et puis la hiérarchie
religieuse qui est elle très puissante
très suivi on l'a vu à l'occasion des
manifestations pour nous donner donc la
réponse bernard benyamin et daniel
mailhot ont enquêté dans les conditions
très difficiles mais je crois que le
résultat de leur travail est très
probants c'est à partir de là que tout a
commencé
c'est à partir du pétrole de ces dollars
qu'un homme a soudain eu l'idée d'une
grande nation d'une grande civilisation
qui allait radicalement changer les
choses dans son pays
le problème c'est que ceux payés
l'iran dont les traditions la culture et
la mentalité n'avait rien à voir avec
cette occidentalisation à tout prix le
problème aussi c'est que la corruption
allait être élevé par la cour impériale
au rang de véritable système de
développement la crise était inévitable
mais elle a quand même surpris par son
ampleur
c'est une crise en même temps
culturelles sociales et politiques
je vous ai dit que à l'époque ce vingt
cinq dernières années le mouvement
d'indignation il pouvoir vis-à-vis du
peuple s'est accélérée plus en plus et
nous on a créé des mythes de toutes
pièces par exemple le mythe de la grande
civilisation perse on ne comprenait le
savait de quoi il s'agissait
le mythe du parti unique le régime a
voulu devenir totalitaire pas embrasser
toutes les couches sociales
il n'a pas réussi c'est donc ici dans le
bazar de téhéran que va naître la
révolte c'est parmi le petit peuple de
la capitale qu'elle va prendre son
aspect le plus exacerbé est peut-être le
plus important c'est l'ong ruelles
sombres cache en fait le véritable coeur
économique du pays derrière ses rideaux
de fer baissés en signe de deuil
il y à des hommes des commerçants qui
spontanément sont venus apporter leur
aide aux plus irréductibles des
opposants l'ayatollah khomeini
depuis une dizaine d'années chacun
prélève sur le prix de chaque objet
qu'il vend une part plus ou moins
importante qui va directement dans les
caisses de l'ayatollah cet argent est
ensuite redistribué aux hôpitaux aux
orphelinats aux familles en deuil ou
encore
aux ouvriers en grève pour la seule
année 1977
on estime que le montant de ces dons
s'est élevé à 30 millions de dollars
la jonction était de fait entre le
mouvement religieux et les bazaris les
commerçants du bazar et ce n'est pas une
surprise puisque les mosquées sont
devenus les derniers endroits où l'on
peut parler
la prière est devenu en fait
l'avant-propos à la discussion
c'est à dire à la politique les sermons
des imams galvanise plus que jamais les
fidèles et ce pour une simple raison la
religion chiite était un moule tout
trouvé pour l'ensemble des formes
d'opposition khomeiny et york capital
bas-pays ti'vac dalle je crois que
finalement la religion est devenue le
point de ralliement de toutes les forces
d'opposition et par exemple voile de
femmes il ya beaucoup de femmes
iraniennes qui ont peur justement elle
craint de qu'elles seront obligées de
porter le tchador encore une fois mais
moi je ne crains pas parce que là le
tchador est devenu enquête sauf si vous
voulez une uniforme de protestation mais
c'est un uniforme de protestation qui
pose un certain nombre de problèmes aux
familles iraniennes
des problèmes qui devait se trouver
confirmer lors des grandes
manifestations de dimanche lundi
la grande majorité des femmes étaient en
tchador
elle était surtout littéralement encadré
et isolé au sein du défilé à santiago
j'ai marché avec dans leurs rangs des
hommes je ne pouvais pas me voir avec
les femmes séparées des hommes face à
c'était quelque chose de totalement
impossible ceci dit j'ai été très
sensible et très très émue à de me
trouver dans cette cette marée humaine
français c'était quelque chose de
fantastique et j'y ai vu une force
politique soulignait pas vu de force
purement religieuse qu'on a vu dans
d'autres pays des mouvements de femmes
qui pendant une guerre d'indépendance
par exemple était très très actif pour
se loger
je pense à l'algérie les femmes
algériennes ont joué un rôle que
personne n'ose ni et et puis pourtant
une la femme algérienne maintenant n'a
aucun droit
vraiment aucun sur ses enfants dans le
mariage et les vraiment relégué au
deuxième plan
et je voudrais pas ta femme iranienne se
retrouve dans une situation analogue
lundi je vous le rappelle journée de
deuil et de grèves générales en ir en
italie maintenant attentat ce matin à
turin deux policiers ont été tués à
coups de mitraillette devant une prison
où ont séjourné
renato courte chaud et ses amis des
brigades rouges l'ibiza le rouge ont
d'ailleurs revendiqué la responsabilité
de cet attentat en france retombées de
la sphère darquier de pellepoix avec
l'ouverture aujourd'hui d'une
information à l'encontre de jean leguay
pour crimes contre l'humanité
jean leguay occupé pendant la guerre la
fonction de délégué au secrétariat
général de la police vichyssoise au
départ de cette affaire une plainte
déposée par serge klarsfeld au nom des
descendants des déportés du vel d'hiv en
juillet 42 à doué procès fera-t-on
l'avocat général a requis la peine de
mort contre l'accusé serge fera-t-on
répondra du crime de sa femme et d'un
enfant de 12 ans et puis justice
toujours le non lieu dans la sphère du
tlm un épilogue qui peut surprendre non
lieu dans la sphère du tlm la cour
d'appel de paris a estimé que le 28
février 75 la présence de l'inspecteur
principal bernard pire sur les lieux de
la fusillade n'était pas une présomption
suffisante de culpabilité quant au coût
et injure raciale dont un avocat maître
benache ne fut victime aucun policier
auteur présumé des violences n'ayant été
formellement identifié les magistrats
ont débouté l'avocat plaignants maître
benache noah décidé de se pourvoir en
cassation
l'ex mari de la princesse margaret
l'ours ne donne 48 ans toujours souriant
s'est remarié aujourd'hui avec une
photographe de 38 ans prénommée lucie
elle paraissait plus tendue que son
époux tony armstrong jones conserve le
titre qui lui a été donnée par la reine
il reste lord
mais ces enfants n'ont pas reçu
l'autorisation d'assister à la cérémonie
qui s'est déroulée dans la mairie de
kensington l'un des quartiers les plus
chics de londres
puis la page de la météo toujours des
vents forts sur la manche
aujourd'hui et puis dans l'intérieur des
giboulées des orages et de la neige en
montagne demain et bien moitié nord en
ferait trop froid même averses neige en
montagne ailleurs pluie et nuages
voilà une page sportive en quelques
télégrammes maintenant alain colas 30
jours aujourd'hui de silence est chaque
jour davantage l'inquiétude intervention
ce matin à l'assemblée nationale dans
l'île berger le président de la
commission des affaires culturelles pour
demander que soit intensifiée des
recherches cyclisme démission d'olivier
du c'est le départ de l'ex-président de
la fédération française de cyclisme est
due à la mésentente qui règne entre lui
et richard marié le directeur technique
rugby enfin du côté de béziers on ne
parle que de la mise sur la touche
pendant un an de l'international alain
estève mais pour la fédération française
ce dossier la violence dans le rugby
était devenu un sujet trop grave
il fallait un exemple il fallait frapper
un n'ont pas poursuivi au sujet comme ça
parce qu'à ce moment là le rugby c'est
pas la guerre c'est un jeu si on le
conçoit différemment mais écoutez il
faut faire autre chose et où tu vas sort
en ce qui me concerne je suis décidé à
assainir le jeu je dis souvent j'ai
prévenu depuis déjà de nombreuses années
tout le monde d'après à passer de jeu
bluffé et bien c'est terminé maintenant
c'est sérieux chacun a pas bien se tenir
et quand je dis chacun ça veut dire aux
joueurs dirigeants et supporters
c'est grave on sait ce que au delà des
sanctions pour le jeu dur pour lesquels
on ne peut pas être contre en général je
crois qu'il recherchait autre chose
à travers ces sanctions et c'est là où
je suis profondément choqué alors vous
êtes choqués mais c'est autre chose
après vous vous avez dû l'analyser et
qu'est ce que c'est bien j'ai d'abord le
club connaissait le thème depuis
quelques mois déjà mais c'est allusion
vise d'autres joueurs de béziers qui ont
eu maille à partir avec la fédération je
parlais des 3p pas parents morts de
paquereau et pamiers selon adrian
ferrasse
il ne s'agit que d'une application de la
réglementation outreman
les britanniques ont les mêmes problèmes
de la violence à réseau il a rendez vous
de l'actualité ce soir sur antenne 2 22
heures 22h40 bars dont le dernier
journal de pierre-alain et puis 12h30
demain samedi et demi la première
édition du week-end thème du magazine de
paul lefèvre les petits trucs pour aider
les automobilistes un petit peu ou pas
très débrouillard et puis un autre
rendez-vous qui nous tient tous à coeur
ici dans l'action je vous en ai déjà
parlé un rendez-vous qui mobilise depuis
quelques semaines tous les efforts des
journalistes d'antenne de la soirée sur
la paix lundi à 20h30 un plateau
prestigieux dont je vous dévoile
d'autres aspects louis aragon john baez
le guitariste césar maroteaux catherine
ribeiro
et puis parmi les documents de qualité
une exclusivité mondiale lim des nations
de verdi une oeuvre
presque inconnu qui regroupe tous les
hymnes nationaux contemporain de ce
compositeur très bonne soirée sur un
ennemi à la 10e'
e
m
oh